hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden unveiling a two trillion
dollar infrastructure proposal which
aims to invest in roads
water systems and electric vehicles
democrats say it will create jobs while
promoting clean energy
while republicans are slamming the price
tag noting funding the bill will raise
the corporate tax rate
to 28 percent fox news study host chris
wallace discusses the proposal
the possibility of higher taxes and
concerns over the humanitarian crisis
at the southern border nasa's
perseverance rover
is settling in nicely on mars searching
for signs of ancient life
on the red planet astrophysicist and
director of new york's hayden
planetarium
neil degrasse tyson shares his insight
on the historic mission
and the future of space exploration plus
commentary from pastor
and fox news contributor dr robert
jeffress
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm kennedy i'm bill hemmer i'm sandra
smith and this
is the fox news rundown
friday april 2nd 2021 i'm chris foster
president biden wants to raise taxes on
corporations and high earners to help
pay for his infrastructure plan the
first major tax hike since 1993 if it
goes through
republicans in congress are against it
but a new poll shows a majority of
americans are in favor of the idea
as a practical rule uh taxing other
people
is popular not taxing you is unpopular
taxing other people is popular
we speak with fox news sunday host chris
wallace i'm lisa brady
after trying times on this planet we
explore other worlds with neil degrasse
tyson
i cannot imagine life without space
and yeah that includes the moon mars and
beyond
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
calling it a win for the future
president biden and members of his
cabinet are promoting his infrastructure
spending plan
transportation secretary pete boudej
tells fox good infrastructure planning
is always about looking to the future
you know railroads weren't part of
infrastructure until we built them
republicans in congress like louisiana
senator john kennedy argue
this is not an infrastructure bill as
best i can tell
just being charitable about 15
of this bill is addressed to
infrastructure the rest is climate
subsidies
and social welfare spending more than
two trillion dollars worth just for the
part of it announced so far with more to
come
it's awfully big and you know i
i can understand everybody agrees there
needs to be infrastructure
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday but at a certain point
and i don't know where that is uh
you know you can't keep throwing
trillions of dollars in government
spending and you know we just passed
uh a 1.9 trillion dollar copied relief
package now here's another two trillion
dollar plan
with another two trillion dollars in
taxes and the president has another
multi-trillion dollar plan
that's going to be just social programs
uh
you know this month of april and
you know you just have to say at a
certain point does it make sense to be
spending i mean even in washington
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars in taxes and spending
is a lot of money yeah this at least
strikes me depending on what you define
as infrastructure as having more
relevant stuff in it than the covet bill
which was clearly
not completely covet-directed this just
depends on what you
what you call infrastructure is child
care infrastructure you could argue that
it is
well i don't know to me that's a social
program i mean there are other things in
this
and i'm not saying whether they're right
or wrong that's up to people to decide
but
it certainly isn't a traditional view of
of
uh of infrastructure i think there's 400
billion dollars in this
for uh care of disabled and elderly
people and i'm not saying that's not
admirable or or conceivably you know you
could argue legitimate
but uh it really is expanding a
definition
of infrastructure to the breaking point
now i i happen to think
that we have defined it in two
old-fashioned a term in other words i
i think infrastructure clearly goes
beyond uh
roads and bridges uh things like the
electrical grid or
you know conceivably having charging
stations all around the country
you're going to have a a nation which
has a
if not a majority certainly a large
percentage of electrical vehicles
by 2030 2035 i think electrical
charging stations make a lot of sense i
would call that infrastructure
child care that that's a bridge too far
from me and i didn't mean the
infrastructure pun there
yeah i just mean when i say you could
make the argument for it
you could say that it greases the wheels
for people to actually work and be
productive if they have child care and
care for their parents and stuff like
that
and now of course this is going to mean
yeah go ahead well i was going to say i
think that's a perfectly legitimate
argument but i don't know how that's
infrastructure
that's a social program and you know you
could argue it's absolutely
legitimate but i mean infrastructure has
traditionally meant
the structure of our country
well in any case they are going to be
very expensive and it's going to mean
higher taxes i wonder if that how this
is
we know of course republicans in
congress aren't going to dig it i wonder
if this is sellable to the american
people
on the basis that look this isn't going
to be your money it's going to be big
corporations money and rich guys money
uh yes i think that is very sellable i
mean as
a as a practical rule uh taxing
other people is is popular not taxing
you is unpopular taxing other people is
popular
there was an old there's the senator
russell long who was the chairman of the
senate finance committee
used to say don't tax you don't tax me
tax that fella
behind the tree and you know that was
basically the the political argument
and taxing big corporations and you know
i i actually see some legitimacy there
they were at 35 most people thought they
were going to drop to 25
uh trump and the republicans ended up
dropping them to 21
which was below even what a lot of
businesses said was needed so raising
them to 28
you know i could understand that and and
taxing people making over 400 000
uh you you can certainly make a case for
that
um so i'm not sure that the taxes are
are uh you know an absolute i my guess
is they'll be politically popular
as long as they're able to keep their
promise and it was interesting the
decision was made
not to because at one point uh the
secretary of transportation pete putice
was saying
well how about user fees you know how
about increasing the gas tax or how
about increasing a mileage tax
you you know you will have a chip in
your car and if it says you've traveled
uh 500 miles this month you have to pay
x amount of taxes uh
on you know because you've used the
roads they couldn't go for that because
that would have broken the president's
promise that nobody making
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year is going to be taxed obviously that
would attack a lot of people
making a lot less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
yeah i mean i guess at some point down
the road again no pun intended
um we have to figure something out
because gas taxes aren't going to pay
for anything when people are using less
and less gas and more and more
electric vehicles right on the other
hand
i was going to say the gas tax hasn't
been raised in i don't know 20
years or so i mean it uh i understand
it's less popular when it when
gas is four dollars a gallon rather than
two dollars a gallon
but you know there is a perfectly
legitimate uh
rationale for raising the gas tax yeah
uh there's talk in the administration
about maybe coming up with some sort of
asylum system reform it's just not it's
just not working out
you got into a little bit with white
house spokeswoman jen saki on your show
last week
the white house finally let reporters
into one of these border facilities and
they're really really crowded
yeah and it makes the argument that the
administration
is making that well we're doing this
because we're humane
we're not like the trump administration
it makes it a a much harder
argument to swallow when you see the
conditions inside these
border patrol facilities uh you know
just just
hundreds of kids with no space at all
as sleeping some of these mylar blankets
literally right next to each other hip
to hip uh
it's a terrible situation and and you
know
you there's just no way you can justify
how uh
the biden administration has handled
this that you know to
to have sent the signal which they sent
whether wittingly or not
hey you know if you come across the
border particularly if you're an
unaccompanied minor you're going to be
able to stay in the country
without having prepared for what seemed
like an
absolutely foreseeable crisis uh strikes
me as malpractice
that just just no way that you can have
have
turned on the faucet the way they did
and and not have been prepared for the
fact that water was going to come out
uh chris what do you make of this story
involving matt gates the florida
conference florida congressman
he's under investigation for child sex
trafficking he denies it he says in fact
he's being ex extorted blackmailed i
can't quite get my head around it yet
have you no uh
you know i mean the answer is uh i don't
know enough about it i mean i know the
reports there seem to be two
investigations going on one in which
uh matt gates the sex trafficking might
be a possible target
and one in which he might be a possible
victim
of the extortion scheme so you know i i
don't know and the government isn't
making uh and you know probably
shouldn't
available the details on these since at
this point it's just investigations
there's no indictments there's no
charges
but uh it sure is a mess and you know
gates is he's he's a uh an unusual
character
and he's taking unusual strategy which
is going out and and
telling his story to every reporter
every television show that will listen
to him
uh i know a lot of good defense lawyers
who would say
shut up you know all you can do by going
public in these cases
is get yourself in more trouble provide
more ammunition that'll be used against
you
you know just remember anything you can
and say will be used against you
and uh you know that's that's the danger
uh when you're a white-collar potential
uh defendant you know you the best
the best policy is to say as little as
possible the baseball season
has started um you think you're going to
get out to watch the nationals at any
point maybe
maybe when the shots are in your arm i
have the shots in my arm
congratulations uh so you know i would
hope to
i'd love to uh i gotta say you know it's
one of the problems
with us in this situation now you've got
the shots
and you know it used to be i'm old
enough i remember the polio vaccine in
the 50s
that you know that that you you you
gotta you had a
a a a a green light you had a
a a carte blanche your life had changed
but now
even though you've had the shots and
you're fully vaccinated
um you know you're still being told
we're a mask you're still being told
social distance except
you know in very narrow cases with with
members of your family or other people
have been vaccinated
so you know i don't know is it safe to
go out to a ballpark now and uh
and watch a ball game i don't know the
answer to that
um i have to say personally i'm a little
leery about it so
you know until i'm persuaded that it's
fine and safe
i'm probably going to watch it on tv
honestly i think i would be fine
the science basically just logically it
seems that you're going to be fine to go
to a game that other people around you
will be fine once you're vaccinated the
cdc
i think now is leaning toward finally
telling people okay once you're
vaccinated
you're probably not going to infect
other people but i don't know how but
then you've got to have
what others at the ball game looking you
know looking at your vaccination papers
uh well i i don't think that they're
going to say that you have to have been
vaccinated to go into the stadium so
i think there'll be some unvaccinated
people there um
i don't know i mean it's the the answer
is do i feel like i'm
uh you know i i have free run and i can
go do anything i want no
i don't feel it yet even though i've
been fully vaccinated and that's
you know part of the problem and they're
going to have to settle this
quickly because i think you know with
the with the huge supplies we have
despite the
complete mess up with 15 million doses
of j and j
um we're going to have enough vaccine
for everybody and then
the big story is going to be and i
suspect by may it'll be the big story
is people who are unwilling or reluctant
to take the vaccine
and i think what's the big key there is
for people to sense
you know to be convinced it'll make a
difference in your life you'll be able
to do things you can't do now and until
you have that
some people are going to say why would i
put this vaccine in my arm
when i don't know whether or not it's
going to make me safe yeah i wonder if
at that point
it really dumps does just come down to
your own personal choice and if you've
been vaccinated you're not going to get
sick if you didn't well
good luck if you're around other people
who also didn't yeah
well we're not out of it now and then of
course you have
rochelle wellensky the head of the cdc
this week almost in peers
saying you know i'm worried about a
fourth wave so uh
we're not out of it yet chris wallace
host of fox news sunday
frequent guest here on the fox news
rundown chris thanks a lot thank you
chris
[Music]
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up it takes a lot of patience
to be a scientist but there must be
nothing quite like the feeling
when something you've spent years
dreaming then designing
then testing works
on the surface
of past life there was
pure jubilation and relief at mission
control
in this case nasa's jet propulsion lab
in southern california
as the perseverance rover landed on mars
in february
the first rover to land in nearly a
decade and this time
thanks to a multitude of cameras
offering new views of both the red
planet
and the rover's own harrowing descent at
nearly 12
000 miles per hour the mission is
scheduled to include a number of
technological firsts
including a helicopter flight a small
craft named ingenuity
carried to mars by the rover and
designed to demonstrate that a
controlled powered flight on another
planet
is possible that's expected to happen
later this month
space programs are among the few things
unchanged so far
by the new administration in washington
white house spokeswoman gent saki
reiterating support this week
for the national space council provides
an opportunity to generate national
space policy strategies
synchronize on america's space
activities at a time of unprecedented
activity
president biden also supports the goal
of landing the first woman and the next
man
on the moon but for now the world can be
captivated by the latest trip to mars
we can't talk about mars without giving
a shout out
both to china and to the united arab
emirates
both of whom sent missions to mars in
this
mars access window astrophysicist neil
degrasse tyson is an author tv host
and director of new york's hayden
planetarium the earth and
mars are configured for good travel
between them
only once every 26 months or so
and so within the last several months
three missions arrived because they all
launched at about the same time
to take advantage of that sort of
orbital dynamics
um china is sending an orbiter a lander
and a rover
the united arab emirates is sending an
orbiter that's going to study the
martian atmosphere to try to understand
what happened some something weird and
bad happen well i don't
value judge it but something happened to
the martian atmosphere so that it can no
longer sustain liquid water on its
surface and there's so much evidence of
water having been there
and now it's bone dry what happened and
so they're going to study the atmosphere
for that
we were the third to arrive with the
perseverance rover
and my favorite part of it is that it's
got a helicopter
that's just mad ass so it's like
rover you're too slow for me let's let's
fly around
and so it's at this stage since it's a
first
it's the first sort of a aviation craft
ever sent to mars
it's a it's really an engineering
demonstration
can it work so we're all very excited
about it
and i know they're taking some core
samples and they're going to leave them
there
sort of hermetically sealed for a future
mission to get those back to earth which
is a whole
other you know realm of new technology
it's a whole nother another and in the
business
that's called a sample return and
because
ideally you want to bring mars to earth
and put it in a laboratory or
or short of that you bring the
laboratory to mars and that's kind of
what the rover
is but you can't bring all of the
sophisticated equipment
because the payload weight is highly
restricted
for these long journeys so you can set
up a series of missions where
you you decide what samples you need and
want and what looks interesting
and then you can send another mission
whose only job it is
to bring the sample back and so then you
can streamline it for just that purpose
because traveling in space is so
expensive and so
it's fraught with so many things that
can go wrong you want to
tighten and sharpen what it is the thing
does because then it could do it
very well what do you say to people who
wonder
why like why do we need to know all this
about mars and do you still meet people
who don't believe it don't believe we
went to the moon or that the pictures
we're seeing are really from mars
especially since they're so clear
so the two questions in there let me
unpack them
and so the first one is what do i say to
people who say why are we doing
it i thought long and hard about that
and yes i'm an enthusiast of science and
of space and stem fields and all of this
and but i can't require in a free
pluralistic country
that you also be enthusiastic about it
but what i can do
is give you examples of
what life might be like without such
knowledge
or insight or enlightenment or better
yet i can analogize you to someone long
ago so let's
let's do this experiment let's let's go
back 30 000 years
and we're all in a cave we're some
tribal group in a cave
all right and you
see the cave door and you you open the
cave
it's probably not hinged okay
you go to the cave opening okay and you
look out
and then you see this this this field of
flowers and then a
river you don't even have words for them
because you're the first to see them
and there's a there's a hill and a and
and
trees and plants and things growing on
the plants
fruit and then you go back into the cave
and say
i want to explore what's out there
and then the cave elders say no we have
cave problems we have to solve those
first
before you go outside the cave and how
absurd that is
right right so here we are on this speck
of dirt third rock from third pebble
from the sun
called earth and to have people say
why are we exploring the rest of the
entire universe
when we have problems here on earth that
we need to solve that feels
a little uh short-sighted to me well
especially when analogized
to that same conversation that may have
actually been conducted
30 000 years ago in a cave so
i cannot imagine life without space
and yeah that includes the moon mars and
beyond
now for those who don't think we went i
i've thought a lot about that too
and here's my conclusion what a world we
live in
where no just think about this where
our achievements are so advanced
that people walking among us
are in denial of them it's to me it's a
measure of how
impressive the advances are they're so
impressive that
some people cannot wrap their head
around it so i said yeah
yeah once you're given applause to to
you you know to human ingenuity
maybe you should be applauding rather
than saying no it never happened
and maybe humans are just cleverer than
you
think we are in total the
the new administration the bide
administration has made it
clear it supports artemis spokeswoman
jen saki is
unambiguous about that um there's still
a little bit of a debate though about
the timeline
for this mission to go back to the moon
2024
2028 there's some funding that's an
issue but from a scientific perspective
is it better to take longer
i don't have a strong opinion there i
often what holds things up is just
funding and political motivation and
this sort of thing
but going to the moon we've been to the
moon so this should not hold us back
the engineering of it should not be what
will not be what's holding us back if
we want to get there in 2024 2028 i
don't have a strong opinion
what i do know is when president kennedy
said let's go to the moon
and he said that in 1961 the speech he
gave which no one re-quotes the rest of
the speech you only hear the good part
like uh you know we choose to do these
things not because they're easy but
because they're hard
we go to the moon and return send a man
to the moon and return them safely back
to
before the decade is out we hear that
but what you didn't hear in the other
rest of the speech is i'm paraphrasing
but we are scared
witless of the soviet union because they
just put up
a man into orbit and we don't have a
ship that hasn't
blown up uh of on the launch pad that
can carry a human being and they're our
sworn enemy
they're the godless communists and so so
if they were doing something better than
us and we were supposed to be the
leaders of the world
that looked bad and so we had motivation
beyond
the charisma of a charming president
there was military motivation so we're
going back to the moon now
uh the timeline is not driven by fear
you know unless
if here's what would happen if this
happens you ready
if china leaked a map doesn't have to be
true
just have them leak a memo saying they
want to put military bases on the moon
oh my gosh
so so that kind of motivation
really puts a flame under people's butts
and
and political machines that otherwise
whose gears turn slowly would then be
rapidly sped up
you do have a brand new book cosmic
queries
star talks guide to who we are how we
got here
and where we're going and that title
kind of plays off your star talk
podcast which was an evolution of the tv
show
um you're tackling some mighty big
questions
in this one though is this just um
something that you've been
wanting to do for a long time cosmic
queries
is a highly successful
format variation of the star talk
podcast and but with star talk has had
many
sort of media incarnations um and
one version of it is called cosmic
queries where we solicit questions
from our fan base and if the questions
are astronomical then it's just me and
my co-host
um but if the if the topic goes be
separate from my expertise we bring on
someone else who is an expert
so so these are fun questions and it
goes the 40 minutes of the podcast
and but occasionally people ask really
deep questions
and they don't lend themselves as well
to the
the witty banter that goes on um with
the comedian and
you know and and the topic so we
collected those
and they're 10 chapters each emanating
from a very deep question you know what
is it all made of how do we know what we
know
how did it all begin is there life
elsewhere in the universe
how how did life form how will it all
end uh and
what does nothing have to do with
everything oh that's chapter 10
that's a good one and so these topics
touch places
where sometimes you don't even know if
you're asking the right question
and if you are asking the question you
don't even know if your answer is a good
one
so this is an exploration and we and and
some of it
borders on philosophical even spiritual
at times but uh but cosmic queries
can it's a celebration of what it is to
be curious
as a book if only we could bottle your
enthusiasm
neil degrasse tyson
[Music]
cosmic energy getting channeled through
to the to this microphone
well we certainly appreciate your
insights as always
and we will certainly talk to you again
thank you for spending so much time with
us
thanks
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon bream host of fox news at
night and author of the new book
women of the bible speak the wisdom of
16 women and their lessons for today
subscribe now on apple podcast spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind last year's easter
celebration felt more like one
unending good friday the light and hope
that easter usually offered
was eclipsed by the darkness and despair
the disciples experienced the day that
jesus died
one year ago there was widespread fear
throughout the world
as the first wave of the pandemic was
raging
countries were on lockdown churches were
empty
things were bleak appall was descending
over the world
and we wondered if it would ever be
lifted
in this last year each of us has
experienced some dark moments
we face the very real possibility of our
own mortality
at one particularly low point last year
my wife and i spent a day searching
for and then purchasing our cemetery
plots
in case we became victims of the
coronavirus
these moments give us a small glimpse
into how the disciples must have felt
on the darkest day in history what we
now call
good friday of course to those who were
living through it
nothing about it seemed good the motley
band of disciples who had followed jesus
all across israel for three years sat
stunned
the one they thought might be the
messiah was gasping for
air nailed to a roman cross the great
hopes they had for a new kingdom
and an end to their suffering felt like
wishful fantasies
but light shines brightest after we've
been immersed in the darkness
that's how easter 2021 has been for me
after months of drudgery the end of the
pandemic
finally feels real to me i remember how
excited i was driving down the dallas
north tollway
a few months ago to get my first dose of
the coveted vaccine
to my surprise during my commute to the
vaccination
site president trump called me from air
force one
as delighted as i was to talk with the
former president
i was more focused on making sure i
didn't miss out on getting to the
location
on time and receiving my vaccine
for me the end of the pandemic brings
some hope
that i can once again experience the
little things i enjoy so much
i can hug my grandkids catch up with old
friends
and visit my favorite restaurants again
this week we
celebrate the single event on which
eternity turns
the resurrection of jesus christ from
the dead
on that dark good friday when the sun
stopped shining and the earth trembled
god was doing something far greater than
anyone could see or comprehend
by his suffering and death christ atoned
for our sins
and made the payment for sin that we
deserve to pay
he was put into a tomb on friday with
mourning
but three days later on that easter
morning he emerged
triumphant over sin and death god turned
the darkest moment in all of history
that good friday when christ died into
the brightest celebration of life-giving
hope
on easter sunday when the world was
swallowed up in darkness
god was working to make all things
bright and new
the good news is that he can do that in
your life as well
whatever pain you've endured this last
year
the resurrection of jesus christ offers
the assurance
that the suffering you have experienced
though very real
is also very temporary one day
as the scripture promises the world's
curse we live under
will be removed and death will be
swallowed up
in victory that's the hope an
empty tomb offers this is robert
jeffress
for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute
news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes